and never look
backs and simply learn to get ahead Jess
Danish a civil engineer turned data
scientist who decided to Simply
learn with a course from a premier
[Music]
University true champion who upskilled
to win
big how big a massive hike that
transformed my life Danish changed gears
pretty early in the race but pron wanted
to explore more to get ahead isar simply
learn from mechanical engineering to a
data analyst and a podcaster in his free
time career transformation bro simply
learn industry expert
live dat
expert
difficult with a well structured course
it felt like a piece of cake that is
simply awesome what's also awesome
longer didn't choose a quick just added
data science into the
Mix N how did you change the game worked
on real industry problems to become the
real deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
Nan from getting ahead what an
allrounder de Hoya night with flexible
learning you can always make it right
bashing your
situation you two will find your way to
get ahead when you simply learn
shortcuts
[Music]
simply
from mechanical engineering to a data
analyst and a podcaster in his free time
career transformation bro simply learn
industry experts
live
with a well structured course it felt
like a piece of cake that is simply
awesome what's also awesome is that no
long career nin didn't choose a quick
fix he just added data science into the
mix Nan how did you change the game work
industry problems to become the real
deal a joint family a regular job
responsibilities but nothing could stop
n from getting ahead what an allrounder
de HOA night with flexible learning you
can always make it right your
situation you to will find your way to
get ahead when you simply
learn simply learn get ahead with simply
[Music]
learn
review session we'll be uh basically
talking about how you can craft a resume
for international career in cyber
security and uh before that um I we
would love to know what exactly are the
problems which you face you know when
you're trying to basically make a cyber
security resume so you can see a quick
one on your screen before we start the
Rie review of resumes here uh so what
aspect of your cyber security resume do
you find most challenging to perfect you
can see few options here uh but in case
this doesn't cover your uh basically
answer here you can let us know on chat
here oh I can see S I have already
enrolled for cyber security Masters
program forar uh so have you completed
already
something or are you still pursuing
that's great if you have joined us you
know welcome welcome uh
so okay pursuing it so basically now
that have you taken over cyber security
course or simply learn so that's great
you're already pursuing it so we
basically can help you out in how you
can utilize the program which you have
taken up you know add those skills tools
project what you learning in the program
so we'll be doing that we have few
resumes like that we have Selected Few
resumes of el as well you know
surprisingly simply learn El have also
submitted their resumes and we will be
reviewing those are helping you out as
well you know if you Tak a program I
think most of the folks have already
voted for this poll so thank you so much
let me quickly share the results for
this one uh so we can see the most
challenging uh aspect here for making a
cyber security resume you folks have
voted for highlighting relevant
technical skills and the second one
telling the resume for a specific job
role I think that is the most offest one
not only for cyber security but others
also in general uh also I think uh you
have third one you voted for showcasing
cyber security projects effectively and
others like crafting a compelling
summary or objective and demonstrating
domain
expertise okay uh let's move on to the
live resume review uh so uh Paris we'll
be starting the live resume review uh
before that would you like to say
something uh before I start sharing the
resumes I think uh the this particular
session I can just say it is interesting
because uh see when I as an interviewer
or as an as an hiring team when I first
look at a resume I don't know the
individual I don't know the capability
of an individual I don't know the
background of an individual the first
impression comes from the page that I
see it on my
workstation now if the if the resume
doesn't talk about the complete story
about an
individual I would probably be in the
dark in shortlisting certain CVS or the
resumés so this particular session is
interesting because it talks about the
elements which are important to be
covered into the into the resume how we
can put a story or Stitch a story
together so that whosoever looks at the
CV they get a very complete picture and
a complete glance of or rather rather
the insight into an individual's
experience and that's where the the
impression starts to
build now that's one part of it the
second part of it is whatever we put
into a resume we have to be ultra
confident about it if we are not able to
defend our CV if we are not able to
defend our resume that's the impression
that's that that we are going to lose in
terms of uh the confidence that we
showcase into the interview discussion
so whatever we write into the CV a we
should be very confident about it even
if we have not done it let's say but we
have learned it
it is okay to write it and put some
parameters to it how confident you are
onto the topic so that you leave some
space for yourself as well into an
interview discussion if you if you get
stuck somewhere you still have that
space for you to get Escape so yeah I
think this this particular session is
really exciting and looking forward to
be part of
it awesome uh thank you so much Paris uh
let me just quickly share the resume
here let me just stop sharing my screen
and share the resumes uh also just to
let you know folks uh we have selected
few of the resumes from the resumes all
of you have submitted and we have
learned your personal details here in
case you have joined here is with us uh
for resumes I'll be sharing right now on
screen uh if you see a resume on the
screen here please do let us know in
chat and you can ask questions to pars
as well you know so that that's a great
way to get it reviewed as well so let me
just quickly pleas share the
resumes okay is my screen visible
yes okay awesome I think we've gotten
the first one from bhat Vishnu par would
you like me to scroll through it once
before we start yeah just to give me a
glance of it sure
sure okay so I think looking at this
first particular page page itself
uh the the profile gives me a very quick
view of this individual that the
individual is a programmer and a cyber
security professional which means the
person has a development background and
that can come in handy when doing a
vulnerability assessment or a
penetration
testing the person also has a handson
experience in developing secure software
applications which means the person can
do the code reviews as well well given a
chance while safeguarding critical
digital assets against evolving cyber
threats
now this evolving cyber threats is is
kind of are words which takes my focus
because then in my interview I will be
asking this individual about the recent
threats the recent incidents that has
happened and if the person doesn't
answer those that's like a you know kind
of a not so good impression for me
having said so overall profile if I look
at the expertise so the person has
experience in Python
java.net Dev secops monack JavaScript
and so on the person also has an
experience on the AWS and the SQL
platform or the database to so this
person comes from looking at the profile
the person comes from a development
background transitioning into a cyber
security uh the person has also done
master of science and Bachelor's of
science from a college with a cgba of 8
and 8.3
respectively the person has done the
certifications like CH if you can scroll
down RHA little bit yeah uh C certified
in devops pen testing from Australian
University Java SQL Developer from
Oracle and then CCNA mcsa Linux and AWS
so the person person has a background of
the operating system the person has an
understanding of the networking the
person has an understanding on the cloud
infrastructure plus the person has done
really uh good certifications into the
uh the development side of it and then
have pursued a certification from I Cano
for the ethical hacking and the
penetration testing so which means that
the person is progressing towards a
particular role now if you really look
at this particular CV the exciting thing
about it is the individual knows the
fundamental of the operating system so
the person knows Linux Microsoft both at
an operating system level the person
knows CCNA which means the networking
Foundation is there and the person is
also relevant in the current market with
the AWS
certification so which completes the
profile for this individual there are
certain projects that the individual has
also done in terms of the penetration
testing based upon PCI DSS and so on if
you can scroll down a little bit
more
yeah so the person has done two projects
one on the PC penetration testing on the
compliance standard like PCI DSS Hippa
CCM and an IST framework and then some
web development for a pharmaceutical
company the person also has an
experience of security Analyst at the
thread cops company and there's certain
things that the individual has put in
now looking at
this it
is it is uh I mean it is touching upon
the sections in terms of what we would
like to see but then it is not into a
chronological order that's one I think I
can spot for example in the experience I
don't know till from what date to to
which date the person has worked in this
company uh that is one secondly if we
look at the uh the uh experience of this
individual uh performing VAP
vulnerability assessment and penetration
testing develop and maintain an incident
response plan these are two different
things so these are contradictory to me
because typically if a person is a
security analyst until or unless you are
a consultant for
example you would be tied to a
particular department so either you
would do a vulnerability assessment
penetration testing and the remedial
implementation of it or you would be
into a security incident response teams
which the person has written and then
the third one is also contradictory one
which is the person is into it
compliance and other teams and
addressing the the GRC part of it so
either the the organization is not of a
bigger scale the organization has a
common role where this individual is
performing everything on his own or the
uh or the person has tried to bring
everything into the flavor of the resume
so when I will be interviewing this
individual my focus would be on the sour
code review because of his background my
focus would be on the vulnerability
assessment and penetration testing
because he has written it in the CV my
focus would be on the 4 and6 as well
because the person has talked about the
incident response plan so I would be
focusing on the rapid response or the
firstand response as well from a cyber
forensic
standpoint my interest would be in terms
of whether the person knows PCI DSS
because he has worked on it whether the
person knows Hippa because he has worked
on it whether the person knows ISO 2701
and so on so essentially whatever the
person has written I would try to
extrapolate that into the larger scope
of the gamut of cyber security areas and
then that would lead me to a discussion
with the individual so if I have to put
this in put this CV if you can go to the
second page visha Rasha oh that's blank
so so essentially uh this is a bad CV
then a I should not have a blank page uh
into the CV it gives me a sense that
this is a incomplete CV and the person
had something in mind which the person
missed uh one pager CV is good enough if
you're not experienced but uh since this
person is experienced I would have
expected much more insight into the
projects the individual has done I would
have expected the timeline of the
experience as well which is missing in
this particular case I would be
interesting in knowing while he has done
the project on penetration testing I
would be interesting in knowing what
result so what kind of results the
individual saw after the testing was
carried out was that was there rather I
would say a glaring critical
vulnerabilities
or is was there something which can be
remediated in a faster span of time so
those things are missing in this
particular CV if it comes and lands on
my table probably I'll keep it for the
second or a third batch to look at uh
the first batch is something that I
would prefer to see a very clean linear
structured CV not in the boxes rather I
would prefer to see it in a very very
structured and a free flow way so that
my eyes can read through it in a proper
way I mean just from a semantic
standpoint I'm commenting but but yeah
experience- wise certification wise this
CV is good uh projects also the person
has done the education also he has tried
to cover so those things are good call
outs expertise he probably can change on
the focus areas or the experience uh in
languages so the person can basically
divide these into two or segregate that
into two because if I look at the
expertise it is more of the development
and only one line of penetration Tes
Dev SEC Ops again is more from a
development standpoint the person may
have done uh because he has not really
done the uh the project on the secure
development he has just developed an
application so so I would uh probably
put this for for a you know later
consideration when it lands to me but
having said so there are certain good
callers that I did like in terms of the
experience and the certif uh
certifications also the education so
these things stand out for me in this CV
but not the other
things uh thank you so much P for ring
this uh let's move on to the next one
but before that I see folks are asking
if they can submit the resume right now
I'm so sorry uh folks who have submitted
the resumes they have submitted this V
resisting for the event there's a link
there in the mail now we have selected a
few resumes for the event but if you
have any questions please put on in the
Q&A box we'll take that in the Q&A part
of the session so now moving on to the
next one uh so this one is by Kumar M
Corner uh Paris
right so there is an error in the email
itself double gmail.com so I would I
would not expect that spelling mistake
in the CV first of all uh secondly the
objective is clear with the double dots
ending the sentence again that's a
typographical error which I would like
to avoid in the CV now the person has
written SE speaking Innovative and
challenging carer
now I would like to when when I'm
interviewing or when I would be
discussing this with the
individual uh I would be really focusing
upon what is a perspective of being
Innovative uh is it like you want to
develop something is it like you want to
change certain practice or what exactly
does the Innovative means so I would
probably in my discussion I would focus
on that word a little more uh challeng
career TOS to secure a position with a
high degree of responsibility and
opportunity where I can utilize my
skills and knowledge to contribute in
achieving the organizational goal now
this overall line if I or sentence if I
reflect back this is
like a copypaste line or a chat gbt line
to me now this really doesn't translate
the emotions of an individual and
doesn't translate the real objective of
the individual this is like a very very
Traditional School schooling kind of a
language where I want to utilize my
skills and knowledge to contribute in
achieving the organization probably a
good objective would be to learn unlearn
and relearn certain things so that I can
contribute to the uh to the business I
can contribute to the team that I will
be working upon and at the same time I
will be growing along with the firm I
think that is more practical and more
relevant more realistic as well uh in
terms of the objective
the summary uh worked at CA Prince Jan
and Company as a service accountant
taxation expertise in income tax return
filing fresher in cyber security highly
skilled and certified ethical hacker so
I would say rather than calling out I'm
a fresher in cyber security you can just
say I'm an Enthusiast in cyber security
field while starting up with the ethical
hacking course that I did with three
months of experience in hack the Box uh
with machine so you can talk about some
of the self initiatives that you have
taken so you can say I'm an Enthusiast
in cyber security with solving the tier
01 2 and three in hack the box and
mitigating the vulnerabilities in uh the
computer system or the network presented
in the hack the Box system so that would
give me an idea that okay you are
learning it but then you are self-driven
individual as well because you're
investing your time in doing hack the
Box testing so that gives me a
perspective into the individual's
profile uh if you scroll down a little
Russia
there yeah so here you have talked about
uh application proven track record of
conducting comprehensive
now this is again contradicting because
at bullet number three you're talking
you're a fresher and in the fourth
bullet you're was saying there is a
proven track record of conducting
comprehensive security assessments which
is
contradictory uh either you're not
fresher or you don't have a proven track
record so either of it can be true uh so
you have worked on the tools like K
Linux BB suit metas Floy qualis nessus
SCM big fix these are all good call outs
but then the more you put the products
specific the more it disconnects me why
because for example if you write nessus
and qualis I would say probably the
individual doesn't have a exposure on N
map which might not be right uh you have
taken a broader category of penetration
testing and vulnerability assessment as
the first two sub bullets uh which are
good because those are the broader level
you are talking about the ethical
hacking tools like k x BB s metas sploit
it'll be worth to put Etc at the end of
it because there are lot many tools that
you can explore and you can utilize
writing qualis and nesses probably you
can put those into a bracket next to
vulnerability assessment and say the
vulnerability assessment bracket qualis
nessus Etc that will help you to
contextualize the discussion Microsoft
secm IBM Big Fix uh these are all from a
patching perspect perspective or from a
remediation perspective you can say so
you can talk about work on the remedial
tools as well likes of Microsoft secm
and IBM Big
Fix uh if you can scroll down
RHA professional
experience uh job responsibility role
fresher in cyber security in CA Prince
Jan and Company worked in online
platform as hack the box and Tred to
hack me worked in penetration testing
machines performing health checks 12th
September joins this maintaining
bookkeeping income tax I would say
refrain from mixing your
experience uh between the penetration
testing or the cyber security and the uh
the the administrative or the financial
side of experience
because Anyone who reads the CV would
get a confused view in terms of whether
the individual so the first experience
is TDS return filing gsta return filing
income tax return filing bookkeeping so
which means that the person is more into
a CA or kind of a financial domain and
then it starts to digress from there and
goes into the penetration testing side
of it so I would say separate out the
experiences in probably into two bullet
points or two subheadings but but
separate out those experience if you are
applying for a cyber
security remove the financial one
probably minimize that into one line if
you are applying for a financial one
minimize the cyber security one but make
it very very streamlined in terms of who
is your consumer who is your audience uh
because that's that's going to define
whether you are shortlisted for the
interview discussion or not so don't
confuse the reader probably it'll be
worth to separate out the experiences
and then you have talked about the
professional credentials as bcom and
then Masters in cyber security it'll be
worth to talk about the college as well
from where you have done the Masters
because that gives a context as
well and if you have done certain
certifications that is uh the cherry on
a because certifications are the
focused educational credential I would
say which which helps you in landing
your CV better the reason I say so is if
I am a
HR I don't know anything about cyber
security I would look out for certain
keywords that I can search into let's
say no.com or any other job portal for
that matter it can be LinkedIn as well
so I will be searching through certain
keywords so let's say if the hiring
organization has given me a keyword of C
or IID or uh you know risk management
ISO 2701 cisp these are all the keywords
for me as an HR if I try to search those
keywords in LinkedIn or in no or C would
not appear in the list so though you may
have experience into it uh but you would
miss on to it if the uh if there's a
tool like in map that is not written in
your CV and I search as a keyword nmap
you would miss out on onto that
particular one so that is where I'm
saying try
to uh bring in certain keywords from the
certification standpoint as well because
that will help you in shortlisting
getting your CV
shortlisted academic credentials are
good 10th from msbe in 2013 10 plus2 in
2015 and then uh in 2018 you joined you
completed I think uh your bcom so which
is fine and and then in which year you
completed your Masters in cyber security
that is a mystery on the CV uh skills
wise knowledge of troubleshooting client
relations and training these are all the
three different troubleshooting is your
technical skill client relation is your
uh communication is your personality
trade and training is your communication
skill so it'll be worth to segregate
those uh skills together energetic and
self-motivated team player I think you
can drop this line because this is
something that any which ways the
interviewer would gauge during the
discussion client management again it's
a repetitive one so you can drop this
bullet point or probably drop the client
relation on the
top and uh knowledge affiliate marketing
online business again you are confusing
here
because you you're coming from a
financial background focusing on the
marketing and focusing on the Cyber
Securities work so yeah confused profile
here I can
say
uh and then your personal details which
is fine so I think the overall CV is
structure-wise it looks good uh certain
sections that probably the individual
can bring in is in terms of the
certifications in terms of the projects
the individual has done that is missing
in here and then bringing in more
clarity about the tools about the uh
education the individual has has
achieved I think that would bring in
more clarity on the
CE uh thank you so much P for reviewing
this resume uh Kumar if you have any
questions with us if you join the
webinar do let us know in chat here and
moving on to the next one this one is by
Manish daa uh and I'll just quickly
scroll through for you before we start
yeah okay so career objective is clear I
think similar comment as of the last uh
CV as well uh try to bring in much more
practicality try to be authentic in
terms of the career
objective uh this is fine work
experience uh he has put in nicely in
terms of the duration the employer name
and the
location and then uh which is fine the
experience talks about okay so I think
one of the changes that this person can
bring in is he has started in in the uh
ascending order I would say start in the
descending order so bring in your recent
experience on the top rather than the
first experience because that helps the
reader in contextualizing the the
experience in a real time uh so okay you
were working at the for dealership uh
working at the for Factory as well and
then so then I see a threee of a gap
difference between this 2014 till
2017 so I think that's where you will
have to probably put a note or if you're
if you're not comfortable with the note
you have to speak about it in the
discussion because that's something
which will get visible but okay you
worked as a senior customer care
executive in First Source private
limited so you transition from a non it
to the it uh side of it if you scroll
down we see that you have worked with
the Royal infield in andman and nicobar
as a service manager so you you go you
basically went back to the
non-it uh and then in 2022 so there was
again a gap of uh two years you joined
uni orbit technology private limited and
you are working here as a senior care
specialist now you have completed the
training on pgcs Design Systems from
simply learn which is good training
program on pgcs build a hacker mindset
and defend against future attacks which
is good your learning the cloud
computing uh completed by Manish daa
okay I don't think so you have to you
know put in the date and the time and
the hour in terms of uh the completion
of the certification or the curriculum
uh you can skip that you can just say
core course Core Concepts course uh come
completed Cloud architecture uh okay
which is fine you have put that again
diploma final year project
repr rof fitting or retrofitting I think
you're trying to put
in uh but that's fine off for rajma the
bus B mechanical year so I can suggest
one thing see looking at your
CV it is more focused towards the
automotive segment of the industry I can
say rather than you focusing on the it
side of it try to focus the cyber
security in the automotive side of it
there is a still a wag in there uh there
is a very good and a decent demand in
terms of the automotive security focus
on that particular area because that's a
growing uh field as of now from a cyber
standpoint and you would do really well
there
uh strength you have talked about extrac
curriculum activities you have talked
about so I think uh overall CV per se uh
there's a lot of elements which are
missing projects on it or security are
missing your complete education I think
that's one of the areas to focus upon
now in extracurricular activities you
have talked about your courses which
doesn't go and fit into the uh the
section heading so you have to really
structure your CV well bring in certain
elements like your experience like the
knowledge or the exposure to the tools
or the platforms uh exposure on the uh
GRC Frameworks if you have any focus on
the projects you have done focus on
really the uh certifications and not the
date and time but rather focus on the
certifications that you have done let's
say from Simply learn Focus onto it and
make it much more linear and uh relevant
strength I think you can leave leave
that particular section that that's not
needed uh but yeah from extracurricular
activities uh NCC is good but then other
than NCC it's all your courses or the
trainings that you have attended so try
to bring those sections into the
training or the certification section
above that would give it a much more
approachable readable theme but uh yeah
and try to put some notes in terms of
the gaps that you have in the working
years as well and like I said as a
suggestion focus on the automotive
security that will be much more
relevant awesome thank you so much P for
reviewing this resume uh let's move on
to the next one uh this is by deashi
shre let me just scroll down a bit for
you to have a
look okay experienced head of IT
department with 20 years of devising and
executing strong it strategies skilled
and leading cross functional team Coster
and Innovation implementing solutions to
enhance overall it performance recognize
for good leadership and formulating it
policies management of risk resource
cocation and so
on key achievements with metrics it
strategy coordinated successful
implementation of it strategies along
with executive teams 20% increas in
operational efficiency by reducing the
long time ad the project deliver
schedule which resulted in 15% reduction
in it cost over a 2-year period led a
team of 143 professionals to achieve.
98% project delivery weight developed
and enforc it governance policies SP the
adoption of new technologies
collaborated with cross functional team
Disaster Recovery plan achieve the 25%
increase okay scr down Russia
it risk management experience it
collaboration experience it
transformation experience St
down okay so a feedback on the first
page it is very text
heavy so for
me uh though the person has bolded
certain words which puts my or which
takes my focus to those words which is
good but at the same
time uh I think you know the the overall
experience obviously is of 20 plus years
which speaks a lot for for itself at
first first glance but at the same time
uh there are a lot of projects lot of
areas of Engagement the person has
brought in uh so because of which it is
too much of a text to be be read if he
can bring in certain if he can reduce
the text on the first page and reduce
the
sentences not necessarily removing the
overall experiences but then removing or
short shortening the sentences itself uh
would help in um in a quick overview of
the capabilities like the first two
sentences gives me a perfect insight
into the individual ual key achievements
and metrics I would probably not look at
the metrics at first I would like to see
the achievements rather and talking
about the percentages I think it is good
call out from the uh
quantification of uh the
experience uh or the value that the
individual is bringing but I think the
individual can R these to say uh you
know there is a substantial rather than
revealing the person can say substantial
increase in the operational
efficiency uh which uh led to a
substantial or a 15 20% reduction in the
it cost over a two-year period so that
would a shorten the three lines to one
or probably one and a half line it is
much more contextual much more readable
led a team of 15 to 30 professionals to
achieve 98% project delivery rate uh I
think this is given because of the role
the individual is performing this is
given that the individual would be uh
focusing on Project Milestones would be
leading a team so this is given in a
role uh developed and enforced it
governance policies that ensured a 95%
compliance rate
now this 95% compliance rate is a risky
number which means the individual is
saying there is a 5% % of
non-compliance right so uh if I look at
a PCI DSS uh I don't know what
compliance it was talking about but
let's say from a security standpoint if
I'm talking about a PCI DSS or if I talk
about uh if the sock kind of a ass
assessment or an audit a 5% deviation is
a very big deviation there because these
compliance standards are not
non-negotiable so even a one error can
lead to a complete failure of the
compliance so 95% I would say refrain
from uh measuring everything into
numbers because there are certain things
which can go negative spearheaded the
adoption of new technologies resulting
in approximately 30% improve Improvement
in user productivity through streamlined
processes adopting user feedback through
service management tools
now here
again if I talk about a 30% Improvement
in a user
productivity uh from a service
management tool perspective I can
understand but then through streamline
processes uh I can still achieve
efficiency by not including a new
technology but rather leveraging the
existing technology so are we trying to
say we didn't had the technology and
then we brought in uh if that is the
case uh then there's a cost element to
it so I should talk about the cost
benefit ratio here in this particular
bullet point because I'm talking about
the Improvement so I should be I should
be uh aware about the cost as
well collaborated with cross functional
team to establish a robust Disaster
Recovery plan reducing downtime by 40%
and ensuring business continuity during
critical it incidents uh which is good
and probably worth a call out if the
individual can talk about a sight level
Disaster Recovery plan or what kind of a
you know Disaster Recovery plan was that
was it a a kind of a resiliency built
into the process or whether that was a
site level uh replication that was done
whether that was an adoption of a cloud
environment from a disaster recovery so
a hint on it would definitely help
achieved 25% in system availability in
up time through proactive monitoring and
maintenance enhancing the overall
business continuity and minimizing the
disruptions so good line to C to kind of
have it in the CV but then again it's
like six seven bullets into the IT
strategy itself if you scroll down into
the IT risk management portion of
it uh involved in Risk Management EV
evaluation with team leads uh during
Sprint activities to track and update
the risk responses to provide decision
making report so I think in it risk
management uh you can talk about how you
have reduced the risks how you have
either averted the risk how have you
built your acceptance strategy of the
risk how whether you have worked with
the insurance companies to take on the
risk insurances for example uh or how
you have negotiated the risk management
principles with the business I think
that will be more valuable because
otherwise from a it risk management
things what you have written down is all
given again as per the role so that is
understandable so if you scroll down
Russia yeah uh I did that's it that's
okay yeah ID collaboration and
communication adopted in widely use it
collaboration tools across location
countries to enable unified
communication collaboration to improve
remote working capabilities using M team
we
conferencing
uh
okay okay so uh yeah I think 70% drop in
volume and saving cost by 40% in DEL
Communication expense uh that's a good
call out in U to have in the CV for sure
but then try to shorten it uh you can
just say adopted and widely used um
adopted widely used probably you can
remove the word and so adopted widely
used it collaboration tool across or
rather it collaboration tool to enable
unified communication and collaboration
resulting in a 70% volume drop while
saving the cost by 40% in the
telecommunication expenses I think
that's that should be good enough you
need not to call the MS steam video
conferencing uh instant messaging and
stuff on so you can just reduce the text
here it
transformation
um okay enhan evaluated and implemented
layer security framework and configured
incident response dashboard 85%
reduction and number of security
incident 90% reduction uh so how are you
sure about 85% reduction in the number
of security incident blocking malicious
payloads using Advanced BC defense
because you sometimes the attacks can go
unnoticed as well so I would I would
very strongly refrain myself from
putting in any number here because uh
these can go
against the uh U the the I would say the
discussion itself so it'll be def
difficult for me to defend uh in terms
of the the qualifiers there
okay as an internal project manager led
a development team for Designing
engineering
department okay sh point you talked
about Erp time sheet okay I think these
are these last two bullet points is
something that you can shorten it or
probably you can remove it as well uh it
will not have too much of the impact
because as an IT director you you are
expected to to lead certain
transformational journey within the
organization and
uh you can just drop couple of lines
there and just to talk about your
experiences but yeah no need to
elaborate on those projects because it
what it is doing all these experiences
is just stuffing your CV in and it is
becoming like a book rather than a quick
glance TV so so
yeah
recording in progress with seven plus
years of experience
uh in identifying and remediate
remediating
vulnerabilities in application and the
networked
systems provided needed oh I didn't get
that line provided needed feedback on
information security fixes okay
resulting in 40% reduction potential
again uh so you have qualified their 40%
reduction in potential cyber threats now
threats are ever evolving
so you cannot quantify there by saying
40% today it can be 40% by the time I
read it it can be 30% so uh you should
not quantify there and you can just say
7 plus years of work experience in
conducting comp uh in conducting
penetration testing on the applications
and the network computer systems and
also working on the remedial fixes of
the identified vulnerabilities that's it
you need not to elaborate much more than
there then profile copsis comes there
LED cross functional teams in conducting
thoro security audits assessing risks
implementing targeted Solutions
resulting in a 30% Improvement in
overall SEC again those 30% are
debatable I would say don't put any
quantification number there spearheaded
the implementation of vigorous
monitoring system resulting in 30%
reduction again U that's debatable
competence in the implementation of s
tools and cloud service migrations such
as o365 Microsoft is your streamlining
data management and enhancing
scalability which is fine key skills
security pro posture
enhancement is not a
skill uh that is a role that you would
do as part of your work so that's not a
skill penetration testing is a acquired
skill network monitoring is a is again a
role security
auditing is again a role but yeah you
can count that into the skill as well
cloud services no cyber security no
incident response yes it optimization no
client support yes so I think out of the
nine skills that you have mentioned you
are getting confused into the role and
the
skill so be very clear in
differentiating what is a role and what
is a skill and call that out in a
relevant section tools and softwares
plunk arite BB suit all these are good
tools to call out uh Amazon AWS kuber
netics cluster Docker Postman bash all
these are good uh tools and softwares uh
to call out for sure uh probably it'll
be worth to differentiate between your
Cloud experience your os's experience
and the tools experience uh because uh
if I look at here parat for
example that's like an operating system
but then I understand it's like a k
Linux but then uh it is an operating
system in itself uh if you have if you
are calling out K Linux then your bb
suit your zap OAS metas sploid all that
goes into the K Linux package itself so
I think it'll be worth to differentiate
between the OS and the tool as
well from the achievements time point
you are the recipient of BU Crow
researcher MVP award congratulations
first of all on that achieved
recognition as the bug crowd's most
dedicated researcher and inducted into
bug Crow April 2019 Hall of Fame so all
these are wonderful achievements and
good call outs uh to have it in the CV
and you have positioned it well as well
I think good professional experience is
something that you may have to work upon
in terms of reducing the text there uh
it'll be uh I would say it is good to
have these bullet points because it
talks about your
experiences but one thing that I see
missing in all the CVS is in terms of
what learnings you have taken out of
these
experiences so for example if I look at
this 2021 to 2023
experience optimize software
configuration and executed updates for
systems uh boosting efficiency by 25%
while ensuring un uninterrupted
operations across different
departments so this is the task that you
have completed similarly architected and
deployed a state of art security network
framework spanning 80 devices Trend the
data confidential confidentiality and so
on again this is like a job that you
have done but then what is really the
learning out of it for you was it like a
negotiation skills that you have learned
out of it was it like a time management
skill that you have learned out of it
was it like a documentation skill or a
communication skill that you have
learned out of it or a patience because
in kind of researching through the
vulnerabilities you would need lot of
patience so I think calling out those
skills out of the job experience would
be good here as
well yeah I think rest is more of a
textual feedback
uh and then lot of places I see
percentages I would like I said I would
refrain from doing it and you have
captured your academic credentials as
well which are really appreciable
courses and certifications also looks
good uh thank you so much par for
reviewing uh giving the resume by ADI uh
please let us know in chat if it helps
you out if you have any questions uh so
sorry folks we'll be like uh stopping
the resume review here because you have
taken 60 Minutes for this now we'll be
moving on towards the program
introduction and we'll talk we'll be
talking about skills project we'll try
to cover as much as possible uh Faris
are you okay with like 10 minutes maybe
like we extend the session oh yes
absolutely fine that's okay okay let me
just quickly share my screen
back and folks who are asking questions
on the chat and the QA box be taking uh
few questions from there as well so now
moving on uh so basically we have talked
about you know what skills tools
projects uh basically what you're
supposed to add for a cyber security
career uh so I'll just uh quickly launch
a poll here and uh basically we would
love to know what is the biggest concern
when it comes to taking up a cyber
security
career you can see a quick poll on your
screen this is a multiple choice
question
okay I can see uh most of the folks have
already voted so let me just quickly end
the ball uh for folks who have joined us
for this webinar uh we'll be sing the
session for like 10 minutes more uh so
we can address all of your queries so uh
I think let me just share the results I
can see uh most of you have responded
that I wouldn't get the Practical
exposure I need to become job ready and
the second one I can't find a fully
comprehensive curriculum program and few
of you have voted that my work schedule
won't allow me enough time for Learning
and another few of you have voted that I
wouldn't get the Practical exposure I
need to
become job ready I think I've said that
already sorry uh so now moving on so
about the program introduction so we
have this IAT campus program of
professional certification program in
cyber security right team uh in this
program you get access to comprehensive
and Industry aligned learning path and
also access to integrated Hands-On labs
and projects we'll be talking about in
the upcoming slides and online virtual
classrooms and it will be flexible to
fit your schedule in case you a working
professional and this program duration
for this one is 6 months and it is
completed by giving 10 to 15 hours per
week uh the eligibility for this one is
uh you need to have a basic
understanding of programming and cyber
security and a bachelor's degree in a
related field with 50% or higher marks
you need to have two plus years of work
experience which is preferred when
you're taking up this PR program in
order to get selected in the program as
well now uh moving on to to the
electives part so the electives here
which we cover in this program which
basically builds your skill cyber
security skills here we start with the
orientation session ethical hacking
vulnerability assessment peneration
testing cyber security Capstone project
and the electives which we have here is
by I khur academic master classes these
are uh this is optional uh the electives
come as a part of the program it is up
to you if you want to take it up
uh and uh basically we won't charge
anything extra for that uh now coming up
to the skills part uh so as we can see
there are so many skills you see on the
screen right now for basically taking up
a cyber security career so uh Paris
would would like to know from you that
do we really need to know all these
skills to start in a cyber security
career or we can start with field what
would you suggest so I think it it
totally depends on the individual's
skills and the willingness as well or
the exist in experience for that matter
so uh for instance anybody who is coming
from a networking background should
focus on the network security can focus
on the vulnerability assessment set
analysis as well uh having said so if
somebody is coming from uh experience I
was just reading one of the questions as
well in the chat and uh the person is
having 18 plus years of experience has
transitioned into the uh cyber security
with the cissp course it'll be wonderful
for him to land himself in the business
continuity for example or data privacy
uh Incident Management data management
identity management these are all
relevant areas for that
individual uh so yeah it is not
necessary to have all these bullets
covered up but some of it would be
relevant to gain a knowledge upon for
example vulnerability assessment would
be a good enough skill for any
individual to possess similarly a risk
management is is a good area to focus
upon because these are something which
is like a foundation to the cyber
security uh data privacy and security is
very in today in terms of the discussion
the lot of governments are focusing upon
it a lot of organizations are investing
heavily into it so it is a good stream
to be in digital forensics I would say
if anybody is really interested into
digital forensics then only land into
this field because uh the job
opportunities are there but then uh it's
not much so opportunities you will find
those are high paying opportunities as
well but then the opportunities itself
is not as compared to others so I would
say yes it is good to have lot of these
skills but if even if you miss out on
three four it's not detrimental so uh
you can pick and choose the skills based
on your relevant experience and take it
ahead uh thank you so much P Paris for
answering that now moving on to the
cyber security skills uh basically we
have many vital roles here which you can
see we can take up for cyber security
career a security infrastructure
specialist application security analyst
cyber security uh software developers
Network Security Consultants uh Cloud
security architect malware analyst uh
security analyst blue team members and
thread hunters and many more uh careers
which you can take up in cyber security
uh now the cyber security tools which
you get to specialize in this program
and libraries and platforms as you can
see few of them on your screen here I
think we have talked about few while par
was reviewing the resumes as well what
basically to include in a resume so as
you can see here toolbox pentex tools
and map kex Google doc B BB suit and
dropex v shark and again like many of
them will be covered in this program as
well which basically will will be
enhancing your resume when when you are
going out and looking for a job in cyber
security Now the projects here so as you
can see that we have this real business
application projects which you get to
work on in this program uh where you
basically get gain access to a victim
machine this is one of the projects
which uh again like we cover here of
vapd on a bank application vulnerability
assessment and exploitation uh Paris
just have a question here basically do
these projects help folks uh when they
are going out and looking for a job how
they can basically add these projects to
the resume you know in order to
basically uh get a job in cyber security
yeah so I think um see the first one
which is gain access to a victim's
machine this is a realtime problem uh
while we are calling it as a project
there are many friends many relatives
many known people that I know uh they
have been a victim of it uh wherein uh
somebody else is controlling or have
control on the mobile or the laptops uh
of the individual so the this is a real
problem to solve
now until or unless we really get into a
problem we would not be knowing what the
problem is we would be looking at it
from a very far distance so once we
learn how to gain access to victim's
machine we would be able to appreciate
the controls which would be implemented
by the organization we would be really
able to visualize the path an attacker
would be taking to reach to a particular
victim machine
and hence there can be certain controls
that we can talk about we can build we
can Implement to make sure that the
attacker loses the excess uh it's not
only you know click play that happens
but rather there's a series of steps
that gets executed before the attacker
gets a victim's machine access so so
yeah I think this is very very relevant
the second one which is vapd on the
banking
application we have a state uh rather we
have a finance capital in India which is
Mumbai and if you really look at
majority of the banks would be based out
of there they would have their Corporate
Offices they would have their it
infrastructure deployed there and
whatnot now if somebody is from Mumbai
or if somebody travels to Mumbai for a
job if somebody has put in on a on a
resume that they have done a VAP project
on a banking application that's like a
eye catchy stuff from the resume s so
yeah this is like a super hot I would
say from a project standpoint the other
important keyword is the PCI DSS here
which is picking up really really fast
from the RBI perspective as well so so
yes the second project is also very
relevant the third one which is
vulnerability assessment and
exploitation this is like a very general
project it can be in the banking World
it can be in the IT ites world
it can be in the retail sector as well
so depending upon where you are based
out of which city state you're targeting
from a job perspective uh this project
would come in handy because this is like
a
generalized uh experience so you can you
can really be benefited out of it all of
this will provide you with a hands-on
experience which you will be able to
respond in the discussion of the
interview you would be able to recollect
the steps that you have executed and
then you will be able to articulate
those into the experience so yeah all
the three are relevant and the real
business implication and real business
challenges as
well uh thank you so much P for taking
us to the projects uh now moving on
there's a Capstone project as well which
you can work on in this program and
showcase to your future employes uh
these cap projects basically mimic real
life business scenarios for True
experien can showcasing your portfolio
uh now moving on uh I think someone
asked about if you provide job assist
Services as well so we have partnered
with IM jobs in this you get access to
job portal resume review and rewrite and
also one one interview Service as well
uh now I think I just saw a very
relevant question Paris in the Q&A Box
by paa here uh I'm just putting down
that on chat for you because we have
gotten a lot of questions on chat so I'm
just putting down this question on chat
for you here so basically paa has asked
that hi Paris I'm learning cyber
security course by IAT cono simply learn
oh uh simply Lear mind I'm transitioning
from functional and gray box QA testing
to penetration testing which CS features
in QA should I learn and project my
resume to get shortlisted I have worked
programming languages like Java Python
and functional
testing okay
so see uh from a you are doing a cyber
security course from I kpur I think
that's first of all wonderful thing
because you will get that exposure and
you would learn those uh tra of the
trade as well you're transitioning from
functional and gray box QA testing to a
penetration testing that would help you
in understanding the business
application because when you do a QA you
go through module by module you go
through URL by URL you go through a
button by button in the app and that
will help you in doing a penetration
testing as well because you have that
level of maturity because of your
existing role uh which CS features in QA
should I learn in Project for my resume
to get short listed I think it'll be
good to talk about the URL scanning
it'll be good to talk about your
business understanding of the
application like you can translate you
can understand the business and the
technology both so that will help you uh
plus talk about certain tools that you
use uh in performing the QA testing as
well though it might not be relevant uh
but then uh but yeah it'll be good for
you to
showcase the the tools on the CV I have
worked programming languages like Java
Python and functional testing I think
these are good call outs because python
is heavily used in the
uh I would say the cyber security World
a lot of modules are written into it
metas sploid uses it Java is also very
relevant so yeah this is a value add to
your CV as well if possible try to bring
in the flavor of python at least talk
about certain modules uh from your
functional testing uh at least from a
load testing if you perform that as well
so do talk about those python modules
because that'll be
handy uh thank you so much par for
answering that surprisingly we have one
more elim from Simply learn and uh I
think this is asish Du uh and I just put
down that question on the chart here for
folks or for you also to see uh so I'll
just read out that question so I have 15
plus years of experience in data
processing automation Incident
Management for infra applications like
cyber Arc net backup and big fix since
last three years I'm working on SSL
certificate management and I'm also
enrolled for the PCP in cyber security
from IAT C program which we basically
are talking about uh kindly guide us as
what should I focus uh if I want to
continue ahead and fully for a in it
security domain and areas which I should
improve for a better salary and further
growth I'm asking this question because
my profile is more of a support kind of
profile and I have no experience in
coding which is required in penetration
testing so I would say a coding
experience is not required in the
penetration testing uh coding experience
do play a element of benefit but then it
is not a required uh it is not a core it
is not not a mandatory skill to have uh
I know for a fact because we we were
hiring a lot of individuals into the
Consulting roles we do hire individuals
into the support roles as well but then
uh we don't really look at the coding
experience we obviously if somebody has
a coding experience that works as an
edit Advantage but that's not a
mandatory thing now you already have an
experience onto
cyber net backup Big Fix so you are good
on the it infrastructure side I would
say than the penetration testing you
have an experience on SSL certificate
management as well so my suggestion is
go into an IT risk kind of a
profile that is one second if you're
really interested in penetration testing
there's no issues in that as well but
then don't go into an application
penetration testing uh go into the
infrastructure penetration testing which
will be more relevant to your experience
so you can do a penetration testing off
and the uh configuration review of Lin
xos you can do it of the Windows
operating system you can do it off the
networks as well so you can do
penetration testing but try to focus on
the infrastructure penetration testing
than the application that'll be that'll
give you a very quick win I would say in
the
interview uh thank you so much panas for
answering that I hope that answers your
question asish please do let this no on
chart here now moving on so we have
talked about the skills we have talked
about the tools we have talked about uh
basically what projects you can add from
this program to your basically career
and resume so I'm just launching a quick
poll uh where we would love to know
would you like to enroll into the
professional certificate program in
cyber security by IAT Cano you can see a
quick poll on your screen and uh you can
see two quick options there yes or no
this will help us understand if you
would like to enroll into the cyber
security program are you interested in
enrolling into the professional
certificate program in cyber security by
ID card and and I think we've gotten lot
of Simply learn Eliz here of the current
program which we talking about
surprisingly so that's great uh thank
you so much guys for joining and I know
that we have been not able to answer all
of your queries because trust me we have
gotten some plenty of questions in the
Q&A box and we already have extended the
session by 20
minutes
okay I'll just keep this poll up for 10
seconds more because I can see a lot of
interest coming towards enrollment of
the program so I'll just keep this pool
live for 10 seconds more so you can
decide your interest towards enrollment
moving on I'll be covering the
enrollment steps and even the program
fee and the upcoming cohort of this
program and for folks uh whose resum
have not been reviewed or you know you
did not know where to upload it uh don't
worry we'll be coming up with most such
webinars uh in in the coming months and
uh like you will you can get basically
attend those webinars as well in case
you are basically interested in resume
enhancement or even interview
preparation if you want a project demo
sort of things so we're covering all
those kind of webinars so please don't
worry about that so let me quickly end
the poll uh I'll give just 10 seconds
more I can see most of the folks have
already voted so that's great and I can
see a lot of interest towards enrollment
and uh let me just quickly end the poll
in 5 seconds so 5 4 3 2
1 okay awesome awesome I saw 80% of the
folks voting for interest towards the
program so now basically how to enroll
into the program so it's very easy uh
three simple steps you need to follow
you need to submit an application here
at askers simple.net I'll share that
after after the slide on chat here and
you need to basically uh basically once
you submit the application your
application will be going for a revieww
and based on that you'll be getting an
ommissions offer letter call from Simply
learns learning consultant and also the
bonus offer for attending this webinar
which you apply for this program and you
enroll for it so now the program fee and
the cohart for this program uh the
program fee for this one is 1ak 145,000
including taxes and we also have
financing options available so in case
you're looking for Emi financing options
that is for as low as
4,935 rupees per month and uh the cohard
for this one which is upcoming is on uh
10 of October the induction will happen
and the classes will start on 18th of
November so in case you have any more
questions you can always reach out to us
at ask us at.net I'll put that on the
chat and just to let you know that for
this particular program we only take 25
to 30 folks per coh uh in order to make
sure you're getting all the attention
that is required you while you're
pursuing this program so moving on for
the folks uh which I saw that have shown
interest towards enrollment uh would
love to know you can see a quick p on
your screen that when do you plan to
exam exactly enroll how soon do you plan
are planning to enroll uh you can see
four quick options here immediately
within 3 months within 6 months or more
than six month now so please uh
basically choose the most suitable
option here uh now for the folks who are
still confused about it just to let you
know that in case you're planning to
join it maybe like six months from now
or within six months you're still
deciding that I would recommend to
select those options because the bonus
offer you'll be getting for attending
this webinar you can utilize that you
know by basically selecting the option
here this is how we'll basically get to
know when to reach out to you so please
do that and while I was speaking I can
see that folks have already started
sharing basically when they do want to
enroll that's
great uh I think satam has asked that
what is basically the coast tenure the
coast tenure is of six months and you
can just give like 10 to 15 per hour
weeks you know to complete your
certification so I think I'll just give
five more for the poll for few of the
folks who have not voted yet uh so 5 4 3
1 okay thank you so
much now basically thank you so much for
joining the session uh we'll be ending
the session now uh thank you so much
Paris for joining us we I'm so sorry we
have extended the webinar by 30 minutes
and uh for Paris you know for being
there 34 minutes thank you so much for
reviewing the resumés with so much
detailing and also answering few
questions you know which we can help
help help out them with cyber security
career would you like to say something
Paras before we end the session I think
U looking at some of the question it is
very very overwhelming and very exciting
to see those questions pouring in as
well but I really love these sessions
because uh these are very practical very
approachable and very relevant in
today's world as well uh personally I
have not seen these kind of sessions
being done by any other organization
than simply learn I think so kudos to
simp for organizing those sessions as
well and really happy to be part of this
group so yeah thank you for having me
here R thank you so much Paris we would
love to have you again soon so uh for
folks basically I get you a lot of
demand coming in on chat while you were
speaking so a lot of folks are attending
a session for the second time as well so
that's great thank you so much Paris
have a good night and for other folks as
well have a good night good evening good
morning wherever you're joining us from
good afternoon and uh thank you so much
everyone please let us know on chat uh
how did you like the session you can
just quickly put on your uh response in
chat here if how did you like the
session how was the session for
you and we'll just end the end this
basically session
quickly okay I can see responses coming
in L it great good good okay thanks okay
fine it's really good okay thank you so
much forone joining we'll be ending the
session now uh thank you see you another
session of sance webinar thank you
everyone